mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a circle contains two semi-circles that
are tangent to each other
also the diameters of these two
semicircles are parallel cords of the
large circle if the large circle has an
area equal to one
what is the combined area of the two
semi-circles
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to get started suppose the upper
semicircle has a radius equal to a and
the lower semicircle has a radius equal
to b
we will then construct a rectangle as
follows
two of its sides will be equal to a
we then have this distance is equal to
the radius b minus a so its distance
will be equal to b minus a
the other side of the rectangle will
have a length equal to a plus b
from here we will extend this side of
the rectangle to be a chord of the large
circle
suppose the length here is equal to x
we can solve for the value of x by the
intersecting chords theorem
we have x multiplied by a plus b
is equal to b minus a multiplied by a
plus b
we'll solve for x
and we'll cancel out the term a plus b
in the numerator and the denominator
thus x is equal to b minus a
we then will simplify this diagram and
we'll consider the following right
triangle
notice we have an inscribed angle that's
equal to 90 degrees
therefore the cord opposite this 90
degree inscribed angle will be a
diameter of the circle
in other words this cord passes through
the center of the circle and its length
will be equal to 2 times the radius of
the circle
we can then use my favorite right
triangle theorem we will have the square
of 2a plus the square of 2b
is equal to the square of 2r
we can square each of these terms and
then simplify by dividing both sides by
4 to get a squared plus b squared is
equal to r squared
from here we can solve the problem
the area of the large circle is equal to
one which means pi r squared is equal to
one
we can then calculate the combined area
of the two semi-circles it'll be equal
to one-half pi multiplied by a-squared
plus one half multiplied by pi
multiplied by b squared
we can then simplify this
and we can then substitute that a
squared plus b squared is equal to r
squared
we thus have pi over 2 multiplied by r
squared but we know that pi r squared is
equal to 1 therefore pi over 2
multiplied by r squared must be equal to
one half
and that's the answer
it's rather remarkable that the combined
area of the two semi-circles is always
equal to half the area of the large
circle
this is true regardless of how the two
semi-circles are in the diagram
i think it's a fascinating result that
two semi-circles fill exactly half of
the large circle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you